hey everybody this is Noel I'm here with
uh you to go through some parts of the
Vulcan Tech gospel volume one which
covers the majority of the basic one
one situation where one number refers to
the hand rotation while the other refers
to the
prop here are we are at the logo this
logo is created by Forest Sterns and uh
this whole thing is compiled by myself
my name is Noel Y and it's been done
with a lot of work of a lot of others um
including David tankboy
caner lur Nichols Brian Thompson Mikey
nope and even Drex had a little bit of
influence on our final
chapter what we're going to go through
now is we're going to go through numbers
two and three uh well chapters two and
three I have a video on transition
Theory you can find on the internet and
that video has got a lot of views and
it'll go through that page for
you moving to this first section this is
the 10 minimal be minimal beat shapes
possible um with two hands so how we get
to this point is we choose shapes that
have one prop rotation for every one
hand rotation and when I say prop I mean
the prop rotates uh on a circle attached
to the hand while the arm rotates on a
circle kind of attached to the shoulder
and our four shapes are isolation
extension vertical anti- Spin and
horizontal
antipin when you take these shapes and
lay them on top of each other and there
bunch of ways that you can do that uh
you get these additional six
shapes in addition just kind of
mentioned some other notes the green
refers ref to a spin pattern while the
red refers to an anti- spin pattern so
for future reference something that's
green and red like this extension and
vertical antipin we call that spin
antipin or antipin spin hybrids and
those can be contrasted against
something like this one or isolation
extension which has two green circles in
it and this would be a spin spin hybrid
and this one down here here this
vertical antipin and horizontal antipin
would be considered an antipin antipin
hybrid we're going to swipe through the
transition Theory section and move
immediately to right here take a look
this one is called this particular
chapter is called the necessity of 40
patterns this was an attempt in the
early days as I was kind of figuring out
Vulcan Tech gospel about five six years
ago I was thinking about about how can I
prove that there is a mandatory 40
patterns that
exist within the Vulcan Tech
gospel well given the base parameters of
10 total shapes um I went about it from
the direction of snapshots or prop
facings we call this a snapshot or prop
facing so I'm going to give you the the
brief tour of the overall layout what
the layout is is it's a quarter rotation
represented um in each little square in
a specific timing direction of hands so
if you look at this column this is all
tog same hands which we also call arm
timing um kind of depends on what the
terminology is we're working that out
but you can see here and this also this
side note these also these shapes look
like unit circle patterns which is
debatable but anyways here we go we
start with our props out in this case
and if you go vertically it starts the
same way out here in one in one out and
you can see that this is dominant when I
mean dominant I mean we chose the top
starting point on every pattern on the Y
AIS and we chose the X ending point or
sorry the left ending point on the
x-axis we could have chosen to end on
the right from the top or from starting
at the bottom to the right but this was
just the easiest way to do this um
another little note is you can see some
of these details are here so the
movement is tog same hands between all
these shapes and we start with props out
and that's the same for everything in
this column if we go to the right we can
see we start with props out in this box
and we do tog op hands and tog op is
this entire column okay and to if you
don't know your timing and Direction You
might want to go back and take a look at
the flow Arts institute's timing and
Direction video for a little additional
help
all right so here we go oh yeah and uh
these shapes here that are were on the
couple chapters ago are basically
projections over the entire circle you
can see that these represent quarter
rotations if we continue those quarter
rotations we would get to this total
shape so it's kind of like a projection
of time via moments within it if that
makes sense to everybody I hope and uh
yeah so here we go I'm just going to go
to this first one you can see that we
start with the props out here and then
we move to the props
in on this example see props in props
out the props in in order to do that
there is only one vtg shape that's
possible that we can do and so if I go
ahead and open up some animations here
that I've prepped um you can see that
here's my pattern we start with props
out
we will go immediately here we'll start
right there so Props out up top and this
one this animation happens to go to the
right but they go ahead and go to props
in and look at us we're doing a vertical
anti
spin okay and you can also see
interesting other interesting notes here
that the hand timing or arm timing is
together Time same direction and the
prop timing is listed on the bottom of
the shape right here okay so for example
number two if we start with the props
out up at the top we go to props out on
the
x-axis you can go ahead and open up that
animation so here we are at the top we
go one quarter Boom the props out we
have to be doing a tog same extension
tog same tog same extension the first
tog same uh referencing the hand timing
and the second referencing the prop
timing this is the case for all vtg uh
props use whether it's a hoop fan
whatever and in this final example you
can see we go from props out to one in
one out and in this case you can see
that we have to make a
vertical antipin and an extension
see we start at the top both props out
one in one out we do this pattern right
here which is a
vertical spand and
extension so there we go and that proves
that there are mandatory shapes created
to transition between specific prop
facings and uh when you go through this
there's a couple interesting liner notes
for example you can see down here um in
the bottom here where it says top
starting with props one in one out to
get from one in one out to one in one
out there's two possibilities where
there're shared
snapshots so be aware of that in
addition sometimes it's hard uh if you
think of quarter rotations from together
opposite just remember that in together
opposite you start at the top with your
hands together and you separate to your
hands on the sides of the
patterns okay and here we are with split
same on the next page and split opposite
some interesting just notes to see is
that you can tell if you go left to
right in almost every shape except for
one in or every box here except for one
in one out it goes one pattern the other
and then the combination of both of them
here it is going straight across
horizontally I go to up the same exact
thing go to the next page the same exact
thing the same exact thing and that's
the case on all of these so there is a
pattern within this and to prove that
there's 40 patterns you can see that
there are four of this red vertical
anti- spin one
two three four and that'll be the case
on this entire
document and I really hope that helps a
lot of people who have been struggling
to try to figure out how this works and
if people still feel like they need help
I would definitely go through another
one of these boxes but I hope that helps
and that everybody continues through
share and learn vtg everywhere oh and
one last comment super extra props
to alien John for generating the
animations that we use in the Vulcan
Tech gospel app that's available in the
Google Play Store and also props to
Kevin who developed that app in the
Google Play Store and Forest Sterns who
created our logo or our first logo
there's another one on the way okay
everybody thanks and if you need more
help on this check out
www vant Tech gospel.com or the Vulcan
Tech gospel Facebook group and there's a
lot of others thanks everybody